yo what's up everybody it is procedure
mad luigi here with another borderlands
zipper sequel video
and this is actually going to be a
pretty short one and it's going to be
concerning the
new uh mission that we got that came out
at the same time of the dlc
and the ultimate ball hunter mode
updates
uh then the mission is the handsome ai
mission that you get from
professor nakayama in the uh hyperion
hub of heurism
and i like is so this is just gonna i
know it's a bit late
the mission did come out a while ago but
i just got around to playing it and i
wanted to show you guys just kind of
what i thought of it
and i have to say it's
it's like i'm i'm disappointed
um because i know there was a lot there
there was a lot of hype
around the mission and uh the dlc
and the ultimate wall hunter mode update
and
there was a lot of gaming websites doing
articles
on it and what it was about and this
mission was supposed to give more
backstory into the tales of borderland
uh telltale game series that came out
recently and it's been released i don't
think it's fully released yet since it
really
they release in episodes and this
technically did offer some backstory to
that
but the mission is it's completely
underwhelming if you haven't played it
so you talk to nakayama then he has you
ask jack a bunch of questions uh
to make a digital ai of jack and you
just you go to this terminal
and you press you activated it like
three or four times and jack responds
with
just his responses to the questions that
you are asking him
and then nakiama proceeds to make that
into it
put the information into a robot that
wants to kill everything
and then you turn in the mission you get
a little bit of xp and some money
and that's the entire mission like you
see me standing here
uh it's that this is the mission this is
the gameplay of the mission
like you see like just you see you see
that that quote those questions and
me standing there and i just keep
pressing e like i like five or six times
actually more than three or four so i
wanna say at least probably at least
five or six and then you go over here
and nakayama plugs it in
and uh and he makes a robot that's jack
and that's it like this this new mission
was like 25 lines of dialogue
and that's it and to me i was i'm
like i just played this mission and i
made this video because it was it was so
short that the mission to here was
hardly any time since like this took me
two minutes
to do the actual mission and see you see
there there's the turn in mission
and it's just i i was just i was baffled
with how short it was
and yeah so i don't know i
i was very underwhelmed with this
mission i think they could have done a
lot more with it maybe you guys think
differently
i was i was really shocked and it seemed
it seems like
like the holodome was all right and it
was they could have done a lot more with
it
and it seems like they're i don't want
to belittle the work
of the developers but it honestly feels
like they're not trying that hard with
borderlands pre-sequel like obviously
they can do a ton with borderlands 1 and
borderlands 2
they did a ton and all the dlcs for
borderlands 2
it was a lot of stuff and it was great
but it feels like they're not really
trying
in this like the the holodome
and this the this extra mission it just
it feels kind of
yeah that's my two cents so hope you
guys enjoyed this short little i don't
know it's kind of a depressing rant but
uh
i don't know i think 2k and gearbox need
to step it up
but yeah hope you guys enjoyed this
video see you all later peace out